much of The Travelers who were trying to
avoid this winter storm yesterday were
not so lucky their flights were rebooked
for today several of them were canceled
again trying to get out of here seemed
to be a quite the struggle now it's not
coming true for hundreds of Flyers here
trying to get home this holiday those
cancellations they could potentially
continue this depends on how the Midwest
storm pans out read International
they've already canceled 75 flights just
today that's on top of over 380 delays
through the Midwest Now flyers they're
telling us they're getting these
notifications either end route or when
at the airport some even telling us the
airlines would not tell them until they
got to the gate not the merriest of news
as they now wait to see if they'll make
it home for Christmas
we didn't get in confirmation email
nothing until we literally were at the
desk our daughter's wedding yesterday
they left yesterday morning a lot of the
wedding was the day before yesterday and
they left yesterday morning got home and
then we stayed an extra day
so which was a big mistake that's what I
want to spend time with my family for
Christmas
yeah absolutely I want to see my
brother's little first Christmas
now flightaware.com they show most
cancellations and delays are coming from
Chicago Denver and the Minneapolis-St
Paul area most major airlines are
offering to waive change fees and fair
differences of passengers choose to
rebook their flights but flyers then
have to make that decision quite quickly
they're then competing for these new
seats with the same passengers from
their initially canceled flight now
several of those people they are still
telling us that they are concerned that
they're going to make it home at all for
Christmas they're telling us that
they're choosing either to drive at this
point they're reconsidering that
rebooking or simply choosing to stay
home this holiday season for now
reporting live at Harry Reid
International Ryan Matthey a news now